go live in the investor tick tock house
yeah exactly yeah exactly the launch
house
the launch house yeah is that what it
was called yeah um i lived at the launch
house for three years oh my god
wow how did you score that
tell us more
you know that application is is long to
get into the launch house what are your
socials like
you're hired for building nuclear
missiles crazy i'm making some crazy
connection in my head right now
which is what i gotta be careful like
hold on do you think you know someone in
the launch house
no but it's someone someone uh
someone knows the founder and they're
raising money and they they hit up devin
and i and they said do you wanna
do you wanna talk to the founder and i
was like i looked at the website and i
was like oh this looks super legit it's
a cool idea
[ __ ] literally made fun of it a week
ago
[Music]
yeah take a laugh dude go ahead and do a
lap around your office
go ahead and do a lap i don't know who i
am anymore am i
laughing business man do a laugh in 10
birthdays or am i a podcast man
dual lap and 10 burpees for that
transgression right there
ah [ __ ] i'm an idiot wow
i'm like launch houses sounds familiar
is what it is yeah yeah
because their website's legit i want to
apply to like google and all my
credentials just be like
six-year member of soho house two-year
member of launch house
it's exclusively like social yeah we're
talking about credentials that's the
credential that matters
yeah soho house baby yeah paying two
thousand dollars a year
to go drink at a bar to pay for drinks
to pay for drinks yeah
you pay a fee to pay for drinks and then
um
pay your friend and and you also pay to
be like yo dude you wanna go to the soho
house six weeks from now
yeah got his table for three um for 45
minutes
yeah yeah sick exclusive he said can i
bring my friend
no sorry only allowed one guest yeah
we're gonna eat beside you know jeff
goldblum probably
so that might be cool and then you go
eat there and then
it's actually weirdly a quiet day and
you're like that sucks
i guess uh i guess fridays aren't
hitting like that weird yeah
yeah and you just like yeah but at least
you'll have some cool story when you
leave like yo dude we saw
lance bass
do you remember joey fatone from nsync
yeah his his sister was there isn't that
crazy
yeah exactly that's sick i always wonder
you know is it worth the membership
price but then you hear stories like
that and it's like
definitely this yeah cause like if joey
fatone's sister's here
dude she looked exactly like him like
sir it was like joey fatone with long
hair
crazy so sick literally like they're
related
it's [ __ ] up man do you remember
taylor lautner
yeah yeah his his trainer goes to soho
house
no [ __ ] swear to god
it's [ __ ] up man [ __ ]
it suck that's what hollywood's about
it's [ __ ] sack this [ __ ] sick
[ __ ] drink a jalapeno margarita sick
right beside taylor lautner's trainer
sick
[ __ ] sick
[Music]
do you remember um bro you remember when
we used to watch will
ferrell there was a guy that looked just
like him at the soho house it wasn't him
though
wasn't him nah that's sick though
i found out because i ran out to him
like yeah step brother and they're like
sir sir covet i was like oh my bad my
bad
i know we just become best friends
and they had to tell me they're like no
fool this is not will ferrell and [ __ ]
and i was like
[ __ ] whatever could have been
hey you're live on the podcast what's up
who is this
oh shoot sorry i forgot you guys are
building
no worries you want to say anything to
the people
no not right now okay okay bye
pissed right now i gave her a chance to
say something to you guys and she said
no
no we're going to bully her for doing
that
she should be our first guest oh when we
when we what we make on our
when we get back in the studio yeah when
we get back in the studio that should be
our first guest our
our agent
you know what i actually i we would like
to know what kind of guests
people would want to see yeah i know
people kind of
like sometimes we have guests they're
like ruins the vibe a little bit but i
think
i think the way we want to do it is like
do some time by ourselves and then have
a guest on
yeah and uh i'm actually really curious
to know what who people
would think would be a good guess for us
to interview let's just find someone
from a stock photo and make them our
guest
and then surprise him at the end by
getting his face tattooed
yeah yo man we're so thankful you came
on the show check this out
and we want to actually show you our
brand new chess piece
this is how thankful we are oh
no why
[Laughter]
because we're so stoked you came on man
as soon as we found out we you agreed to
it we went got blasted
[Laughter]
just got blasted
it's a little name on the side of the
finger
what's crazy is holding up a hand
blasted and saying just got blasted it's
like
you just fingered yourself like
yeah that's true just got blasted
yo two fingers nice
no fool she got a tattoo
yo speaking of blasting off
so i used this bad boy yesterday
my vr headset if you're just listening
and i played
a little bit of phasma phobia
so it's a horror game it's it's been out
for a minute tons of streamers have
played it so i'm you know i'm definitely
late to the meme
but yeah i was just gonna try it out
on stream and so steven and i we
we play a quick round first of all
horror games in vr
so [ __ ] it's it's like it's not fair
no because it's not like a haunted house
where you're you're kind of like oh
it's for fun and you know it's like oh
look at the makeup and ah you got me you
know
cause the way phasmophobia is you're
ghost hunting so you start in a truck
and you have to like load up a bunch of
gear and then you have to go into the
house
and the the player movement is so
unfucking believably slow that you're
like if this was me in real life i could
take off running but knowing that you're
just pinned to this [ __ ] like
movement speed where it's just like
yeah that's how you're like when the
ghost sees you you have to run away
because it will kill you
um and the the game is super interesting
because you have to call out to the
ghost
so you learn the ghost's name and then
it's the code is written so that it's
like picking up
all the players being like you know when
we played it was like sarah thompson or
some [ __ ]
so you have to like go around with this
like little ghost reader
you have to be like sarah thompson are
you there
and then like it will actually say that
into the mic yeah you have to like speak
and it will wait is it multiplayer yeah
someone else playing the ghost
no it's like written into the game so
it's like you and your friends are just
basically going ghost hunting
whoa that's sick it is actually and it's
creepy as [ __ ] because like
you know the one i did we go into this
log cabin and all the lights are off and
the ghost will do [ __ ] like kill all the
lights so you might like get up to the
third story and you've turned on all the
lights like
and then all the lights shut off and
you're like well it's not fun
and yeah
and so um
you know i'm starting to get that like
this sensation i started like feel
sick from vr which is like super common
and
it was the worst being scared and
wanting to vomit it was just like so
brutal but basically we get down to the
living room with a cabin
and it's so weird to talk about this
because you know telling it back it's
it feels like i did it you know what i
mean like oh we went to this house and
like whatever
and so see i'm playing with seva
and the one creepy thing i hate about
like
game models like in vr is like the it's
not perfect
so the whole time steve's character like
it doesn't blink
and like the hands are all [ __ ] up i
was like dude we have to go
over here to find the ghost i'm like i
already
don't look at me let me do that [ __ ]
and then so he puts the reader down on
this little table
you know his eyes are open he's like
sarah thompson are you there
sarah thompson and right behind him this
like the lights flicker and then she
shows up
ah and it's just her eyes got the
shivers damn
her back and her head are facing me and
she's literally doing this
[Laughter]
like crazy fast
and i instinctively dude i'm standing
in the middle of the room and i
instinctively just go like this i just
go
that's it like are you good just one
scream and see what starts busting out
see he was dying laughing he's like yo
take a picture take a picture
because i got a camera from er so then
that's when the awkward part is i'm like
in vr trying to get this stupid [ __ ]
camera
and i'm like i'm recording you i'm
recording you
oh you just carrying it up on her um
yeah and then
we go back in the truck and see he was
like [ __ ] you got the wrong camera
that's have fun when i you know i'd be
having fun when i show this video to the
cops later
get out of this house
enough say it you can say to the camera
i'm recording you i'm recording you this
is going right onto facebook
so yeah it was uh and then and then i
took the headset off and i
legitimately wanted to just puke
everywhere but
i'm kind of stoked because basically i
think everyone i've talked to
says like yo you just use you got to use
games like that for like a week and then
you're good
and i'm actually hyped to play it
because it was i don't know
it was kind of dope to just in three
o'clock in the afternoon to [ __ ] my
pants with fear
it's kind of sick i kind of what was it
called phasmaphobia get it we should all
play yeah
yeah i'm down and it's on the valve yeah
it's on the index okay
so i guess you can play it on anything
right it doesn't matter but did did that
make it feel cooler like
oh yeah the motion detectors and
everything were like was reading your
body and stuff
and does that [ __ ] work yeah and and uh
siva was saying like when you die you
can you're like basically like another
ghost
in the house so like you can help people
or you can scare them
siva said he found two shoes
in the um in the house and he like went
up to the other players and started
walking them on the ground
like towards people and they're like
what the [ __ ] dude that's [ __ ]
awesome so
wait you're playing online with other
people yeah you can you just join a
lobby and just like go
sick yeah and like there's other [ __ ]
where
you um like the ghosts will
chase you more if you're screaming so
like if if they hear your voice they
come after you so like the people that
like see the ghosts go
and like run away and like scream their
ass off that's who it goes after oh man
this is like making me
feel bad it's i'm really getting like
the shivers
dude it's a creepy ass game
yeah and like so that's the other thing
is you have to hide
and you you're supposed to like not talk
she has to like go into things
and it could just be in there just going
crazy
[Laughter]
dude when it came i was like
the light goes on it goes bruh bruh bruh
bruh
dude when she popped up in the living
room i'm like what's my primary
what's my primary yeah yeah i so badly
wanted to blast this [ __ ]
blasted whoa kenny
got a blast got a blast yo wait
hold on wait ready
wacky slash that thing bleeding to the
yeah i mean whoa kenny whoa kenny
rocky slides that thing bleeding pete
you have to say it's slightly wacky
slash
i'll stop slash
you